what are you doing down first hush I'm
trying to be in Kakariko bam hush I have
to be on the low I have to be on the low
cuts I'm on the wall that's it that's
who we have to do we have to start with
that yes we do but we have other stuff
it is a tense movie in Tyler Perry's
Madea franchise last month the picture
opened at number one that's why we're
starting with it grossing more than 21
million dollars in its first three days
go you the entertainment mogul is a
mastermind behind 19 theatrical releases
20 plays and 7 TV shows he's also Oh
by-the-by a best-selling author Perry's
just out with his second book hire is
waiting as the name of it it's a
collection of inspirational stories and
teachings it's meant to help people
enrich their own lives but in 2013 we
featured Tyler Perry in our very special
note to self series he wrote a letter to
his 13 year old self encouraging him to
climb higher to get through tough times
growing up that's a searcher young face
for any sign of myself
believe it or not I'm able to smile
because just behind all of that darkness
I see hope
[Music]
you've got some kind of faith in God
I know you don't know this right now but
who you become as being shaped inside of
every one of those experiences every one
of them the good the bad yes and even
the really ugly ones they got really
ugly - we're happy to welcome Tyler
Perry back to studio 57 good morning to
you Tyler morning it is good to see what
I like it number one this book is so
candid but you you made a point of
mentioning the note to self
and how it affected you because I always
think of us as a viewer watching it how
it affects us it didn't occur to me the
effect it must have on the person doing
it but it really affected you writing
that note - oh okay sure yeah looking at
those four young pictures of myself and
actually because it wasn't just an
exercise it was actually talking to my
younger self and let him know they would
be okay is a part of it it's very
healing and I've since passed it on to a
lot of people and friends who are going
through I said you should try this
because it was really a catharsis for me
as well well you talk about it because
in your life this is a very personal
book yeah you write about your childhood
a life of discouragement unthinkable
abuse you said and belittlement
especially from your father Tyler yeah
What did he say to you what did he do to
you and how did you get through that
well what didn't he say oh what he what
can I say on morning television but you
know and for him having a third grade
education and and the difficulties that
he went through as a child growing up he
had no references to be a father he was
a wounded man trying to raise a wounded
child but but he would say all kinds of
things and there was all kinds of anger
and abuse and beatings and and things of
that nature growing up but looking at it
now I understand this I was able to
forgive him because I spent some time
trying to understand where he'd come
from and what he had been through once I
was able to get that information it
allowed me to have the even the
possibility of being able to forgive him
and put all of those things in the book
how did you have such deep faith my
mother my mother my mother didn't have
millions of dollars to give me but what
she had was great faith she believed in
God she believed in Jesus she would take
me to church and I'm grateful for it
because what I know this day is that if
you don't give your children something
to turn to they're going to turn to
something in hard times so for me the
was she gave me God I didn't have to
turn to drugs or any other thing to get
relief or make it through you dedicate
this book to to your son yes to my son
but but read Charlie wait Howie the
dedication is so beautiful yeah I had it
right for a Mon yeah for Mon hold on for
a mom my son and son beat of my heart
and healer of my soul yeah it's like
your dad taught you how the dead not to
be yeah he taught me in Reverse I wanted
to be a father I didn't have our one day
I was very frustrated I'm like how could
I be a good father how can I figure this
out and I realized that if I do the
opposite of what he did I'd have my
answers so when I call him my son my
healer he is definitely that because as
I look at pictures of my young self and
I look at him every time I say I love
you to him I'm saying and love you to
the little boy that I was we didn't get
that love every time I hug him um I got
me I look I mean we look just alike you
get a second chance yes that's
absolutely right your son absolutely
right in the book you talk about
trusting your soul GPS yeah what is that
well it's just just like when you get in
the car you put your navigation in to
where you want to go you there's a
satellite above you that's guiding you
you don't know how you're gonna get
there especially if you've never done it
before I went to that destination before
it's the same way I believe that like in
prayer and faith and for your dreams you
put that into your into whatever your
soul's navigation and let God be the
guide be the be the satellite above you
that guides you through everything to
get to where you want to go eternal
you've now officially have an empire
you've bought a big Fort McPherson army
base that is going to be bigger than
Warner Brothers by the time you're done
with it
but you talk about the days of living
paycheck to three days before Patriots
right when you were living in your car
right yet you still kept thinking I'm
gonna make it somehow yeah there was
always this spark of faith and I go that
goes back to tremendous faith and my
mother just having that moment of
because no matter how dark it got she
always took me to church and we always
believe that things will get better and
and I totally have her to thank for that
he went five miles a day and listens to
country music don't know the title of
take one step at a time yeah me you tell
me what you mean by that well just if
you're if you have a dream and a goal
and hope and you're trying to get to it
you yeah I'm the kind of person I want
to see major changes big broad steps all
at once but sometimes it's one little
at a time but if that will advance you
further sometimes you get pulled back
and you have to just take one step at a
time but you have to also applaud and
pat yourself on the back every time you
make one step forward because it is
leading you to a higher place you give a
good analogy about trees yeah trees are
very important in your life I think this
is a good definition you look at people
as trees yeah
and some people are leaves some people
are leaves they come into your life for
season they're there when the wind
changes or blows too hard they're gone
then there are people or any life over
branches who are attached to you a
little better but you don't know how
much they can handle until you really
put some weight on them and if you put
up too much on they can break and leave
you but what you want in your life or
roots and roots don't have to be seen
people don't have to know that they are
there and if you have a few roots in
your life you have just enough to keep
you sustained and keep your life healthy
and full and grown I was surprised in
the book you said you accept criticism
that you're open to it because when I
would call you with concerns about your
movie they're not made for people that
live in Greenwich Connecticut it doesn't
sound like somebody who's accepting
criticism I'm open I'm open to criticism
yeah we'll come back the movie on I got
concerns about this one oh girl it
opened number one thanks on sale now